mindfulness is significant I think the
reason it's so significant is it speaks
quite directly to to so many of the
forms of our modern dis dis ease I'm
going to characterize them in in quite
general terms you can find your own ways
characterize them but you know very
often when we teach mindfulness courses
people will say you know just feel my
life is getting faster and faster
there's too much to take in
I'm always looking ahead to the future I
just want to live my life fully I want
to experience things in the present
moment and there's connection between
all of that which is clearly to do with
the way our society is changing and and
the kind of difficult experiences we
have like stress anxiety and depression
which are also to do with our minds and
the fact that our minds aren't within
our control we can't stop worrying by
deciding to stop worrying so we need we
need something more subtle if we if
we're going to engage with that you know
mindfulness is happening on that level I
personally think it's also quite a
significant source for social change
I mentioned Parliament and there is a
lot going on in Parliament with interest
in mindfulness in supporting mindfulness
but also a difference seeing that the
approach we have in mindfulness where
we're not can not looking ahead to the
future we're not thinking about our
experience in terms of what we can
achieve it's not it's a non instrumental
way of thinking about our exile
experience that that actually is very
relevant to a lot of the the policy
issues that politicians have to think
about you know we live in a target
driven culture psychologically we know
that targets and the idea that we're
monitoring we're measuring ourselves
against some kind of ideal causes stress
and distress that's a lot of the
psychology behind the mind post moving
well what if the same applied on the
social to society as a whole how we
think about public services
but I think it's it's worth just
noticing that this maintenance movement
has resonance in in those kind of ways
you